(air whooshing)
(clicking sound)
- You and I are talking
to each other right now,
through technology.
Had there been no internet...
This fucking Corona happened in '88,
we'd all be fucking not
interacting, really isolated.
We demonize technology when
technology brings happiness.
(upbeat hip hop music)
(men exclaiming)
You got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
Here on this beautiful Tuesday, March 24th
and I'm excited to be
with all of you guys.
I hope everybody's doing well.
I know the Corona,
COVID situation has a lot of
people in different places
and I'm here to sip some
tea and answer some Q&A.
Thank you for everybody joining.
Thank you for people
joining from Community,
Facebook, Instagram, all the platforms.
We're live on Facebook.
Please share the link.
- [Dustin] Hey Madison,
you're on with Gary.
- Madison, what's good?
- What's up, dude?
(chuckles)
How are you?
- It's going well.
- Pretty good, man.
Not gonna lie, I haven't woke
up this early in a while.
It's been back to back mornings.
I'm in Arizona right now so
it's like six in the morning.
- I appreciate that.
I'm flattered.
What's good?
- Nothing much.
Well, first, it was funny
cause I came and saw you in LA
and I actually met D Rock in the bathroom
and I pissed right next to him
so it was pretty funny to
meet D Rock in that manner.
(laughs)
- I love that.
Is (mumbles)?
- What's up?
- He did a good job?
He was respectful?
- Yeah, I don't know if he
washed his hands, but...
- D Rock!
(mumbles)
I had a thought about not washing hands
but that day is done.
I'll be washing hands forever.
- Right?
I'm just messing, he
washed his hands but...
- What's good?
- So my question is,
well, I'm super grateful
for you dude and...
Well yeah, my question is,
so I do door to door sales
for this company called,
Vivint Smart Home.
And the reason why I'm
doing door to door sales,
it could be arguably,
one of the hardest sales
that you could do, but more importantly,
I'm getting sales skills,
leadership skills, people skills,
as well as just learning
the grit and the grind.
I don't really love what I do right now
but I understand the fact that I'm gaining
a lot of skills to fully develop
and hopefully become an entrepreneur,
and my question is, is,
what I'm doing right now,
is that the right steps
to become a successful entrepreneur?
- It's not?
Or are you asking me if it is?
- If it is.
- First and foremost,
let's take a step back.
Do you have a sense of why
you wanna be an entrepreneur?
- Yeah, so, I kind of...
The sense that I have is,
I kind of had a taste in my mouth
with the job that I have now
with becoming an entrepreneur,
creating your own schedule,
working for your own,
and on your own time.
- You like that flexibility?
- Yeah, loving the flexibility
as just well as, you know--
- Do you like the sale?
Like you get, high, excited, high energy
when somebody on a door
to door, says, "Yes?"
- Yeah, it's pretty
invigorating just knowing that
I can knock a door and
in 10 minutes I can--
- Make money.
- Exactly.
- Make money, but...
- I get it.
And the game, the game?
- Yeah, having someone trust me enough.
- Yeah, figure out how to tell Sally
that she needs this thing?
- Exactly.
- Yeah, no, look, I think sales
is an incredible foundation
to entrepreneurship because
I think a lot of people
might be good operators.
I see a lot of people in my circles
and a lot of people I've worked with
that are great at operating
something, being a manager,
but they aren't a great
sales person and money,
and the ability to sell to make money
is the oxygen of a business.
So, I do think you are
building a foundational piece.
There's a lot of other things
that go into entrepreneurship.
You know, managing people, for sure,
is a huge one that has nothing
to do with what you're doing now, per say,
unless you're managing
a team and motivating
and so that you're getting
into that a little bit.
But you're not in the same place.
Different things of that nature.
But yeah, I think it's a core piece
and I think at this young of an age.
And I think, asking you
those questions of like...
Just even your smile to
like, "Yeah, I like it."
Like, having love for the
close is a big piece, bro.
Now, what will really be interesting is,
are you the kind of kid
that's better off making
100 to 800 k being a head
of sales for a company
versus being the owner
of a business, is real...
You know, to make that
same 100 to 800,000,
that's a big deal.
There's a lot of people that
have businesses right now
that do two million a year
and they take home 310
and they don't fully love
it but if they were just
the head of sales of a company,
they'd be making 590 and loving life
because they wouldn't have
to have all the baggage
of all the pressure on
their fucking shoulders.
I think that's the crossroads
that you have to figure out.
Are you a big-time sales person
or do you wanna be an owner
operator of a business?
And you won't know that
until you actually go through the reps
but you should know that
we're in a time right now
where entrepreneurs on this
pedestal is fucking cool
and that's what's tricking you.
Fuck what's cool.
Focus on what makes you happy.
Fuck that entrepreneurship is cool.
Do you love it?
And then do it.
'Cause if you don't, you might
be much happier loving it
being a head of sales or
just being a sales person
in something you love selling.
- Gotcha.
- It's a huge (mumbles), bro.
Don't get caught up in the hype
because let me tell you
something right now.
This Corona thing sits for awhile,
entrepreneurship is not gonna be cool.
- Yeah, right.
- Government bailing you
out is gonna to be cool.
Stable job is gonna be
cool, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Entrepreneurship is...
You know, now that nobody
is gonna be able to rate,
I got fucking a hundred
emails on LinkedIn yesterday
of people begging me for help
because they lost their funding.
Entrepreneurship's cool when
somebody else is paying for it.
But a lot of people have
to build their businesses.
Now everybody thinks
you have to raise money.
A lot of people had to build
their business from scratch,
that's real grind, and right now,
the money's not gonna be flowing
to fucking 25-year-olds with ideas and so,
just figure out if you
love entrepreneurship
or do you love sales and
you're young enough to try both
and then take it from there.
- Great.
So what I'm trying to get into right now,
I have a team, like, I
have about six people
that are underneath me
trying to become that leader.
Try to get into the manager role
so I'm trying to get a
little taste of that,
but would you recommend in any other way
to taste the entrepreneurship
that you were talking about?
- Buy something in bulk
and try to sell it on Amazon and Ebay.
- Okay.
- Learning supply and demand
is another great thing
you could do on the side
and figure out if you
like selling product.
- Okay.
- Literally pick whatever you can afford.
Take, 500 bucks, a thousand bucks,
buy something, and flip it.
It is an incredible skill
of learning how to market
and sell in supply and demand.
- Sweet.
- Just don't make it hand
sanitizer and be a douche bag.
(Gary laughs)
- Or toilet paper.
- I love entrepreneurship,
but exploiting people's
fears is lowest form.
Cool, bro.
I'm trying (mumbles) a lot today.
I'll talk to you soon.
- All right, sounds good
Gary Veen, thank you.
- Of course.
- Later man.
- Later.
- [Dustin] Ashley said
she'll Skype the video.
Okay, here's Alex.
He's coming in right now.
- All right.
Let's get our shit together
this morning, boys and girls.
People are turning in
to Gary Vee's clunky.
Alex, what's good?
Alex.
- [Dustin] Just takes a second.
Oh, there you go.
Alex, how are you?
- What's up Gary?
- How's life?
- Not much, man.
It's cool talking to you, man.
- Cool talking to you.
Where are you from?
- I'm from North Carolina,
north of Raleigh.
- Awesome man, how old are you?
- I'm 16, I'm a junior
in high school right now.
- You enjoying this vacation or what?
- It's kind of cool, but, it
is what is is, can't complain.
- It was exciting at first
but now you're realizing like
being stuck in a house
is like some bullshit?
- Yeah.
It tampers with everything and
I can't do anything anymore.
- I get it.
What can I answer for you, bro?
- So, my question is to you, Gary.
I wanna major in music
performance in college
but my mom is heavily discouraging me
and she's unwilling to pay for my tuition
or so she says, at the moment.
- Right, so, I'd probably trick her
and sign up for the major that she wants
and then second day of school,
go in and switch your major.
- Yeah, I thought about that, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean what is she
gonna do at that point.
Or, or, super man up and go
into debt or work a side job
and pay for it yourself.
I mean those are really
the two moves, right?
- Yeah, of course.
- Or number three, give it a college try
on what she wants you to do,
some bullshit that she thinks
is safe and will pay more
based on the world that she grew up in,
not where the world's going
or around your passion
and eat shit for a year
and give it a shot.
Those are really your...
You got three simple options.
- Yeah, of course.
- You know?
- Yeah.
- Like, good news,
they're all good options.
I wouldn't dwell on it.
I have a lot of respect and
empathy for 16-year-olds
who are like, "Fuck!
"This sucks."
It's like, I remember
the shit I worried about.
We all worry about...
You can't worry about the biggest...
Everyone worries about their life, right?
- Yeah.
- So I don't look down on this worry.
At the same token I'm super happy
'cause I think all three options
you have are all awesome.
- Yeah, of course.
Thank you man.
- Yeah, man.
It's really just putting
things into perspective.
Like you fucking won.
You're gonna be like all
three are gonna be good.
Even if you decide...
What does she want you to major in?
- She wants me to do accounting.
I wanna be an entrepreneur and musician
which I know it seems a lot
but she just wants me to do accounting.
- She just wants you to do something
that she thinks is safe
because she loves you.
- I know.
That's why I understand.
- I mean getting some
foundational understanding
of deeper financial infrastructure,
probably won't hurt you
so maybe you sign up for that for year one
and see what happens,
maybe you'll be surprised,
take away some value, or maybe
after a month you're like,
"Fuck this shit," and
you go switch your major.
- Yeah, but in music in
college you have to audition
to get in to the music program
once you first apply at the school.
- And so are you gonna...
Got it, got it.
So, look, a couple things.
What do you wanna be with the music?
- I wanna do saxophone and
piano performance in jazz.
- So one of the things I
like about the game of merit,
of skill is, it's a skill game.
Obviously, people that
go to the top schools
are gonna have "easier
path" to the league.
It's like going at
Florida or Alabama or USC
or Michigan for college football
but the NFL is riddled with guys
that went to Juco, that didn't
have good college careers.
Shit, Tom Brady was a backup
his last year in college
which is why he went sixth round.
But if you're the fucking
goat, you're the goat
and so one thing to keep in mind is,
even if you don't go
down the path of getting
into a great music school,
if you're fucking good enough
at the fucking saxophone,
you're gonna be able to do it.
(mumbles) it's different now.
They don't just look for the schools,
like post fucking videos on TikTok
of you crushing the fucking Sax.
Like the world is so
fucking different bro.
You're so blessed to
be living in this time
when it's not just like,
"If you don't go to
Julliard, you don't..."
You know, fuck that shit.
(mumbles), it's just different now,
so just remember that
if your path isn't going
and trying out for school
and then going to that school
and then getting into the performance
but your path goes around it, and...
Good news, if you also
wanna be an entrepreneur,
it's never a fucking straight path.
So getting used to zigging
and fucking zagging.
I almost...
Hearing that you wanna be
in music and entrepreneur
almost don't want you
to go to a music school
and want you to do some fucking videos
on the corner of the fucking street,
crushing the saxophone
having people come up to you
and then somebody wants you to perform,
do you know what I mean?
- Yeah, I got you man.
- Good man.
Hope you have a great day.
- Cool, you too.
Thank you, man.
See you later.
- Thank you, take care.
All right Dustin, let's go fast.
I like speed.
- [Dustin] Matt's gonna try one more time.
I told him to take off his headphones.
- (mumbles) Matt another chance?
- [Dustin] You know, I'm
an empathetic person.
(Laughs)
- All right, dude.
- [Dustin] Here he is.
- All right, Matt.
- [Matt] Can you hear me better?
- [Dustin] Yeah, much better.
- (mumbles).
- All right.
- Fire away.
What can I answer?
- All right.
Sorry.
Shoot, the question.
So the question was,
how do you stay focused
and keep yourself on task to
achieve more overall success?
- Just in general?
In the macro?
(Matt clears throat)
- Well, specifically.
- Yeah, take the notepad away.
On some real Shit, do you find yourself
not being able to stay focused?
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
- Have you thought about the fact that
you just might not like what you're doing?
I did think about that but
I think I heard (mumbles)
He said, "It may not be
that you lack passion,
"it may be that you lack a calendar."
And so I think that's really the problem
because I definitely love what I'm doing.
- Which is what?
- I work at Nickelodeon.
I'm an animator.
- That's awesome.
- What's that?
- That's fucking awesome.
- Yeah, I love it.
(chuckles)
- And so what's happening?
Like, you also might love
the craft of animation.
You just might not love the
structure of Nickelodeon.
- It's not really so much at
work, it's more after work.
- Well what do you want
to happen after work?
I wanna get more things done
with the time that I have after work.
So, I wanna work on personal
animation projects of my own.
Outside of animation too, I
wanna get other things done.
I kinda want to make a podcast
or write an app or something
towards some kind of meditation,
self development app.
Other passions that I have--
- So what happens?
You get home and you just wanna Watch TV
and like video games and
chill and talk to friends?
Like you don't get goin'?
- Well, so I have a three-hour
commute to and from work.
And then at work I'm usually
there eight to nine hours
so I usually don't get home
until around eight o'clock
and at that point, it's like,
I need to go to sleep around 11:30
so I can wake up to do it all over again.
I always feel like I
get home, I eat dinner,
maybe I do a little talk to my family,
(mumbles), but I don't
feel like I have the time
to be productive or even actually
sometimes finding the time
to do things that I like
to do which is fun things.
So it's kind of like trying to find...
I'm trying to find a balance
of being able to be productive
but still have time for other things.
It seems like I can't do either.
- Makes a lot of sense.
Have you considered
rooming with three people
in a shitty apartment
closer to Nickelodeon?
- Actually, I lived in Manhattan.
I live in New York which is where I work
so I lived in Manhattan
which was only 15 minutes away by bike.
- Too expensive.
- Say again?
- Was it too expensive?
- Well, I did it for two
years and at some point, yeah,
it became too expensive
so I decided to move back
and live with my family in the Bronx.
It's a little further but
I save a lot more money.
But I did do that for two years.
And it was still like,
even though I got (mumbles)
I found it difficult.
- Why did Bronx take
three hours to commute
or are you saying an
hour and a half each way?
- An hour and a half each way.
- Got it.
- Yeah.
- So what time do you leave work?
- Usually 6:30.
- Got it.
Yeah, I mean look,
I think there's a couple
things that run through...
What about weekends?
What are you doin' on the weekend?
- Usually I have the weekends free
but I usually like to spend
them with my girlfriend
and my family.
- Fair enough.
- Once again, it's a difficult thing
'cause I will wanna
spend time with my family
and my girlfriend and my friends
but I want to have that
time to get things done.
- The biggest thing that I think...
How old are you?
- 23.
- Yeah, you know, my answer
and I'm sure Jay's answer makes sense
and I'm sure a lot of people have answers.
My answer is, I think you're
beating yourself up too much.
I think you're being
impatient for the side stuff.
- Okay.
- You know, I didn't really start doing
what I needed to be doing for myself
until I was 34 with Vayner, right?
I was kind of in the liquor store
dealing business for my family,
so I'm just thinking
at 23 in a world where
you do wanna spend time
with friends and family,
which I think is healthy,
when you do have a job
that you actually like
and you're good at,
pay bills, like save money, that's smart,
you're back home, I love
that, the humility to do that.
I kind of like everything you're doing
except I think you just might be impatient
and might be beating yourself up too much.
Like why can't you do the other
things that you want at 32?
I'm being serious now.
32 is a fucking child.
- Yeah, I've always thought that--
- When you're 23 it's hard
to think 32 is a child.
- Yeah.
(chuckles)
I've always thought that
when I got to my 20s,
I'm like, "Oh my God, things
are running out of time."
And now I see your videos
and I'm always like,
"What if I chill?
"I'm not even close to 30
yet, I have so much time."
So, I definitely think that way.
- I feel like I have
unlimited time, I'm 44.
I'm double your fucking age.
I think you need to slow
down you beating yourself up.
If you start a podcast in two years
that will be super young and super early.
I think you're over analyzing
and beating yourself up too much.
- Okay.
- I really do.
Like, I get that you
wanna do side projects
and start a podcast and
build a fucking app,
and we all have ambitions
but when it starts turning into
something that's negative...
Ambition is a very interesting game.
I watch people convert
ambition, like a chemical,
into something very negative.
And I see people turning
into something very positive.
I think you need to
try to convert it into,
that you don't suck and you're unmotivated
and you'd fucking need meditation or drug
or a fucking cult to be a part of.
You can just take a step back
and fucking realize you're doing so much.
Bro, you just laid down some real
fucking shit that I respect.
You're working hard at
a craft that you like,
you had the humility to move
back in with your family
at a young age to be
thoughtful about saving money,
you are meaningfully
spending time with friends,
family, and your girlfriend.
You're doing a ton of shit right.
I'm sorry that you haven't fucking started
the great fucking next meditation app yet
or the fucking number one podcast.
I'm sorry that you're not
calm or fucking Joe Rogan yet
but you're fucking 23.
- Yeah.
- Bro, take a step back and realize
how many things you're
doing that are smart
and give yourself a little
bit of breathing room.
Like save some money,
enjoy your early 20s.
You can start getting
serious at 42, let alone 27.
You need to slow it down.
Your ambition or ideology
is creating anxiety
that it doesn't need to create in a world
where you're gonna live for,
and let me say it slowly to your face,
another fucking 90 years.
- Yeah.
(chuckles)
- You understand?
- Yeah, thank you for saying all that.
- Makes sense?
- Yeah, I get it.
I feel like that is what I do.
I feel like I can see it myself
and I gotta slow down
with being impatient about
I wanna get things done right.
But like, what do you think
I should do until then
to at least feel like the
time that I have after work
is still something productive?
- Realize that relaxation is productive.
Realize that like slowing
down a little bit,
catching up with friends at 8:30
is a fucking good, productive thing.
Productivity doesn't
have to come in the form
of the output of a business thing
or an output of a making of something.
Productivity for your
soul and for your humanity
is fucking great.
- Yeah.
- And by the way, the weekends,
you might be able to find
three hours to be productive.
'Cause your pot committed to 48 hours--
- But then, that's the thing.
That's the thing, is, so
I'll see my girlfriend
usually two, sometimes two and a half days
of the three-day weekend, you know?
- Makes sense.
- 'Cause I don't see her
during the weekdays much,
I wanna spend that time with her.
But when I get home, let's
say it's like Sunday,
the end of Sunday, I'm like,
"Okay, I have a few
hours left in this day."
Then at this point, it's
like I feel like it's me
that's getting in the way
'cause it's not that I don't
have time in that situation,
it's that I can't get
myself to just sit down
and do something.
- Stop beating yourself up
and realize that right this second at 23,
a fucking child, you're just not motivated
to do the podcast or the app yet.
It's okay.
- Okay.
- One of the greatest
strengths that I have
is not beating myself up.
I have plenty of times
where I can just take
a whole year and not be as productive
as I want or miss operate
the business for a year.
Just don't beat yourself up.
You will do it when you're
ready and you want to.
- Okay.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Or, I would take downtime
into consuming information
that might lead to an unlock for you,
but don't think of this
as a negative, dude.
- Okay.
- Enough with that.
You're not lazy, you're not unmotivated,
you don't have a blockage.
You just don't want to do it right now.
- I don't know.
I think I really wanna do it but I--
- No, no, no.
You don't.
Your ideology...
You think you want...
The ideology is to do it
but your actions are...
Actions over words, bro.
If you wanted to do a podcast
you'd fucking run after hanging
out with your girlfriend
on Sunday at 4:00 p.m. and come in
and fucking build your podcast.
You like the idea of the podcast,
you like the idea of the app.
You like the idea, but right
now you don't want to do it.
- So you think I want
to do it, just not yet?
- Maybe.
I also am scared that you want to do it
'cause theoretically it looks
good to you in your ideology
versus it's actually in your fucking soul.
- I don't know.
I mean, I'm an animator at
Nickelodeon, which is great.
I love animation, but
I think my real passion
is actually helping people and--
- Then focus on content.
Lets start there.
Like, let's focus on TikTok.
Lay in your bed on Sunday afternoon,
literally flip the
phone, fuck The lighting,
look at how shitty our both
settings are right now,
and just talk to the fucking kids.
You wanna help people?
There's an unlimited
amount of kids on TikTok,
there's an unlimited amount
of opportunity right now
on TikTok to get organic reach
when nobody knows who the fuck you are.
There's unlimited opportunity for you
to look at the trending hashtags.
Pick one, figure out how
you wanna talk about it
and tell a kid a story
about how at 23, right now,
you're struggling, "And I know you're 16,
"and I'm still a kid and I
talked to Gary Vee last week..."
You wanna help people, good news.
It's called flip your
fucking camera around
and talk to the fucking
world on TikTok specifically
'cause you'll get reach
because that platform
still has organic reach
and you'll be able to help a bunch of kids
and you were just a kid four minutes ago.
Talk.
- Okay.
- Right?
Everybody wants to help the world
but then they wanna make it complicated
and build like a $7 trillion app
that costs a lot of money and is slow
and takes nine months and raise capital
and find a fucking development partner.
It's all fucking impractical.
Take your fucking phone,
flip it to your fucking beautiful face
and fucking tell somebody something.
- Okay.
- Make sense?
- Yeah, it makes sense.
- Scratch that itch.
If you like me, if you
like Shetty, I get it.
I'm listening to you, right?
Cool, try it.
Try it.
Just tell a story.
Right now people should tell stories.
Tell a fucking story on TikTok.
Call it "Story Time With Fucking Matt"
and just tell a story.
Be like, "Hey, when I was 16,
"this fucked up thing
happened and I got through it
"and you can too," and that
just might help one fucking kid
on the other side
and then you'll scratch
the itch of helping.
- Okay.
- All right, bet.
- I just wanted to say one more thing.
My brother, he's a huge fan of you too.
He wanted me to ask you a question.
- Okay, (mumbles) 'cause I
got a lot of people (mumbles)
- Yeah, quick.
He just wanted to know, how
would you recommend balancing
having fun with school and work and all,
anything that needs to be
something that you'd have to do?
- You guys clearly share DNA.
This is about--
- Yeah it's a very similar question
but imagining it's not from my situation
where it's just he has
a lot of things to do
and it's not that he
doesn't have the drive
for something else it's just,
how does he actually
find time between things?
I guess it's what he wants to show.
- You guys share DNA,
this is about judgment.
I'm telling about judgment
about your (mumbles)
You know what I mean?
Like, you gotta take a step back
and the answer is like, whatever.
Let it go.
Don't over-analyze balance.
Just fucking live life and
stop fucking overthinking shit.
For who?
For what?
- Okay.
- All right.
- All right, thank you.
Bye.
- All right Dustin, let's get this goin'.
Thanks, Matt.
Good questions.
(Mumbles)
This is fun.
"Tea With GaryVee" everybody.
- [Dustin] We got Ashley coming on.
- Okay.
Hey, Ash.
- Hey, sorry I had a
customer this morning.
(laughs)
- Customers first, always.
I was taught that a long time ago.
(Ashley chuckles)
- All right, so I didn't know
I was gonna be on the call
but my first question,
I did have a question
'cause I had a moment where I was like,
"Maybe this is not gonna
to work out for me."
So I have a smoothie business
and my husband and I, we've
been trying to expand in Houston
and I guess it's so hard
'cause you see all your colleagues,
they're expanding in their
cities, like everyone's on fire
and then you're like,
"Ignore it, focus on what you're doing.
"You're doing the right thing."
And some days, I would think,
"Maybe I'm not really cut out for this,"
but the other day I was
thinking, I was like,
"I'm totally cut out for this."
- Do you like it?
- Yeah, I really like it.
- Let's stop for a second.
Before whether you're cut out
to be an entrepreneur or not,
definitely before,
who gives a fuck about how other people...
Like, nobody's life or expansion
of their fucking smoothie shop or bakery
or fucking cookie shop or coffee shop
has anything to do with you.
People spend so much time in envy
about how somebody else is growing,
it's just a complete and
utter waste of fucking time.
If you start with, you like
it, and I kind of believe you.
Like, I watched you with the customer
and even just the way
that you just answered,
so, I actually believe
you which excites me.
What you need to spend
100% of your time on,
is the customer.
Like, spend every minute
that you're worried about
Melissa's milk shop and
Karen's cookie shop,
every second that you spend on that,
focus on your fucking customer.
Like that customer that you just served,
ask them, "Hey, what
else could we serve here
"that would excite you?
"What else do you want?
"How do you like it?"
A complete obsession
about your customer...
A, you like it, complete
obsession about your customer,
everything else has a real
high chance of working out.
It doesn't matter if you're cut out
for it or not.
Whether you debate it in your head
or your uncle's debating
it behind your back
or if I'm deciding from the side lines,
it actually doesn't matter.
What ends up happening, ends up mattering.
Including you failing in this venture
and then restarting it
a year and a half later
with a different spin on it
and fucking winning that time
and then being able to
shove it in everybody's face
who said you weren't good enough.
And most of all, most of all, Ashley,
if you like it, you're fucking winning.
You have to understand that.
If you actually like it, you're winning.
There's plenty of people who are building
successful QSR companies or
who are making a ton of money
in their job who hate it, who
are losing compared to you.
I'd rather stress about
making a mortgage payment
'cause my business sucks shit
but love building that business
than fucking having a
fucking golf club membership
but fucking hating my job
because that's fucking 50% of your life.
You take away sleeping,
fucking work is (mumbles).
I mean, are you kidding me?
If you fucking love it, you fucking won.
Of course, we want it to be successful,
but debating whether you're cut out for it
right now or not or
worrying about somebody else
doing well is dog shit, fuck that.
- Agreed.
- Right?
- Yeah.
I mean I do love it.
I love what I do.
We've been doing this now for two years.
I take care of the business myself.
My husband's like really
trying in the background
and I left...
I used to be in oil and gas.
I went to school and it's not
that I hated my eight to five,
I just hated the lifestyle that I had
and here it's like, I get freedom,
I do work way more than
what I used to work.
- Of course.
- But I love what I get to do.
Like the impact that
I have on people and--
- Are you guys in trouble
right now cause of Corona?
- Well our numbers have been affected
but I watched your live yesterday
so I really liked all those
tips that you were giving
on small businesses like, doing the videos
so I have a different marketing plan
for my next 90 days
'cause my usual marketing
is not gonna work with
what's going on right now.
- What's your (mumbles)?
- I'm sorry?
- What's your usual marketing?
- Our usual marketing
is business to business
and we schedule people
for like a smoothie day.
So it's very one on one person
but it draws in a lot of
people, new people that week.
- This is the time to build brand
around Ashley the human
being and your company.
You need to put out two
videos, three videos today.
One on Instagram, one on
Facebook, one on TikTok.
You have to promise me that, Ashley.
It is videos about you that
will make this business grow.
I mean it.
Tell your story.
Your story of, "I was in oil and gas
"but I fucking hated it and did this,"
will resonate with 43% of Houston.
(Ashley laughs)
Right?
- Yeah.
- You know?
Listen to me, put yourself out there.
Literally hang up right now,
take this positive energy
and take your fucking phone
and make a video and just
be like, "Here's me,"
and just literally fucking
post it on the Instagram.
Start a TikTok account, yesterday.
Yesterday.
You have a TikTok account
for the business yet?
- No.
- Good.
Literally hang up right now,
take the energy and make one.
Don't know how?
Google how to sign up
for a TikTok account.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- You're in full control.
- Don't think about strategy,
fucking do the strategy right now.
What's the name of your business?
- Ignite Nutrition
- One more time?
- Ignite Nutrition.
And do you have an Instagram account?
- Yeah.
And what is it?
- @ignitenutritionclub
- Ignite...
I can't spell for shit.
Is this your brand or is it like a--
- Yeah we made up the name.
- Awesome.
- Club.
Beautiful.
Iced coffees, duh duh duh, Houston, Texas.
Good, I just followed you.
Now, here's the good
thing, I just followed you.
Here's the bad thing,
I'm gonna fucking stalk the
shit out of your account
and make sure that you're
doing what I'm taking about.
(Ashley laughs)
Listen to me, make videos
about you and your story.
Do it right now.
Use some hashtags in your post
and then make a TikTok right now.
I want two TikToks from
you a day, every day.
I'm telling you right now,
you're gonna send me a crying
happy email in seven
weeks about what happened
with TikTok and your business.
Are you offering delivery?
- Yeah but it's hard cause
it's only me right now
and I have a girl who
comes in and helps me.
She's my friend.
But mostly people are coming
in for take-out or curbside.
- Understood.
Make fucking content, make a lot of it.
You're fucking sitting around
with less customers' foot traffic.
Don't sit and dwell and think
and debate if you're cut out for this,
make fucking videos now.
I wanna see a video...
I want you to make a video
of every individual drink
you have, how you make it,
and how you thought about it.
- So make the video and post it
on Instagram, TikTok, Facebook?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- You have a Twitter account?
- No.
- Create a Twitter account, post it there.
Making fucking content
is how small businesses
will get out of Corona.
- Okay.
- See ya.
- Bye.
All right "Tea With GaryVee"
Advice for all here.
Everybody's listening,
I see a ton of comments from everybody
that they're happy with the
advice they got yesterday,
they're happy with the
advice they got today
but I need fucking action.
I need fucking action from all of you.
You gotta fucking make.
Who's next, Dust?
- [Dustin] It's Darcy.
- Hi Darcy.
- Hi. How are you?
- I'm well, how are you?
- Good, thanks.
- What's cooking?
- So, my question for you is,
how do you deal with a negative friend?
- You limit your interaction with them.
- Okay.
- It's real life.
A friend is not to be cut out.
A friend is to be quarantined.
(Darcy laughs)
- That's good advice.
- You basically need to do to your friend
what you're doing to the Corona virus.
- Okay.
- You're gonna have to
spend less time with them.
You should also be up front with them
that you're gonna be doing
that and that you love them.
I mean, obviously you're
already getting emotional
so this is a long time friend?
- Yeah.
- Best friend?
- No.
- But core friend?
- Yeah, for sure.
- That's awesome, listen--
- It's the kids, it's the kids.
- Meaning?
- She's got kids.
- And?
- So they try and keep in contact
and stuff like that so.
- One more time, her kids
are friends with your kids?
- Her kids keep in contact with me.
- That's sweet.
- Yeah and so it's been hard
because she's super negative
and I wanna keep in...
Huh?
- And they're keeping in contact with you
because they're getting
positivity from you?
- I'm guessing.
I'm not a hundred percent sure
but I've been a friend with
her for a really long time
and her kids look to me as
like an aunt, kind of thing
which is awesome but--
- You can be there for them
without interacting
with your friend as much
and I'm sure that that will veer up
and your friend will reach
out to you and be like,
"Fuck you bitch, you're not taking to me,
"you're talking to my kids.
"I'm not gonna let them talk to you."
- She usually make
Facebook posts about it.
- What's that?
- 'Cause I don't feed into it.
I don't feed into the negativity
and then she'll go and post
on Facebook about how...
Without using my name.
- Of course.
Sub tweet it, I get it.
So, listen to me,
doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
You're strong enough emotionally
to deal with the subtle jabs
even though it hurts your heart
and you're doing this for the kids
which is incredibly noble.
- Yes.
- I also think at some point
it's not against the idea
of potentially reaching out to her
and having dinner and
really going there with her
and telling her that you love her
and you know, maybe that
one conversation sparks her
going to therapy or
recognizing something in her.
Like, I always think a last ditch effort
with compassion but candor, right?
When you mix compassion
with candor, right?
When you're not attacking
her, you're like,
"I love you, but this is fucking shit."
I think you'll always feel
good when you're 92 that you...
Too many people cut people out
or tell them to fuck themselves back.
I think you go with compassion and candor
and it's something that you
are grateful that you did
when you're 90 years old.
You feel like you did all that you could.
- Right, yes, okay.
I like that idea.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Like truly with compassion, be like,
"Listen, I'm not here to judge you,
"I'm empathetic to you.
"This is DNA and
parenting and environment.
"I love you.
"We've been friends our whole lives.
"But listen, this is really tough.
"And this is like tough on me.
"I find myself pulling away
"'cause the negativity is unbearable.
"Your kids, you know, I
wanna be there for them,
"I love them because I love you.
"Is there anything I can do to help you?
"Please, like tell me."
"Fuck you, fucking Darcy.
"You think you're better than me."
"I don't think that I'm better than you.
"I just love you and I
know what's happening,"
and then cause you know her, you're like,
"This is why Kevin doesn't
talk to you anymore.
"This is why Rick broke
up with you in college,
"but I'm here, I've been here
and I don't want to disappear
"but I can't sustain this
level of cynicism, negativity.
"What can I do for you right now to help?"
That kind of delivery gives
you a fighter's chance,
a puncher's chance, to maybe fix it.
- Yes.
And I'd like to help her
because she's got such a
damaged past in her life
that I'd like to be a positive support
but she just puts so
much on me that I can't.
Especially with everything
in the world right now,
I'm learning who is really super negative
and who's gonna come out positive.
And we just choose to be positive
so it's hard to even hear
any of this negativity.
- If you look at China, South Korea,
even Italy in the last 24
hours, if you look carefully,
there's plenty to be positive about.
We're all gonna get through this.
- Yeah.
- And by the way, some
people are gonna lose jobs
and some people are gonna lose
family members, it's tough.
But life (mumbles).
People look at the negative.
I'm saying to friends like,
"Hey, I know you're scared
"but what if the Corona
thing didn't happen,
"you were living your normal life
"and today was the day that
you were gonna get hit by a car
"crossing the road and dying?"
Everyone looks at the obvious negative
instead of the not obvious negative.
There's a lot of things
that are gonna happen.
Somebody today, stayed home
and didn't do something
that they would have done in real life
that would have led to
their death or unhappiness.
- Right.
And they didn't even know.
- Correct.
So anyway, listen to me.
- Okay, listening.
- Compassion and candor.
- Okay.
Two good words.
- I think so.
And when you mix them together
and you come from a good place
which clearly you're coming from,
if nothing else, when you're 92,
you would have done the best effort
you could have.
- And that's what I want.
I only want what's best for her
but she doesn't wanna hear it.
- Correct, which means
that you have to come at it
from a different angle
and maybe the mix of compassion and candor
because look, candor's
been very hard for me
over my 44 years.
I've gotten better at it
but I'm still not there.
Positive people tend to struggle
with delivering negative points of...
You know, you're having
a frank conversation
with you and saying, "You're
fucking negative as fuck."
(Darcy laughs)
- Yes!
- (mumbles) probably something
that doesn't come natural
to you given how I See
you already, so, I get it.
I'm gonna say it again.
Upfront compassion with candor
might be something that works.
Might be.
- Okay, well, it's a good
angle to take anyways.
That's all I was looking for.
- I'm happy to deliver it.
- You're the best.
I'll see you later.
- Thank you.
- Welcome.
That was really nice.
Good one, Darcy.
All right, where we going next, brother?
- [Dustin] We have Becky.
- Becky.
Let's do it.
I like this run of ladies.
- Hi, good morning?
- Good morning, Becky.
- Thank you for your time today.
- Happy to be here.
- My question, I'm getting
so much great information
from what you're answering for others
but I am in the health field.
I'm a health coach
and with a very heart-based
service industry,
like many other people,
this has sparked us to want to do more
and in fact, I was thinking
of Matt earlier today
and thinking maybe if he thought
about who he was serving,
it would spark him to get motivated.
But what I'm running into is,
I wanna give everything away for free
and while I want to and plan on
and had planned on now have
great ideas for more content,
I also have to charge
and provide for my family
so my question is, where
do you draw that line?
We wanna put tons of great content out
and I have a program starting
but if it were up to me,
I would do it and never be paid
but the bills will come,
so that's kind of--
- I understand.
So this is something of a fine line
that I think I've done really
well in the last 10 years.
I think it's about intent and
I like where your intent's at.
Let me give you a really
good point of view.
I think where you draw
the line is at intent.
Let me explain.
I think anytime you put out content,
you need to put out the
best possible content
you can for free.
The problem is, you're getting
voices that are telling you,
"Hey, don't be a sucker.
"You gotta provide for your family."
You know, whether this
is your internal voice
or outside people, like,
"Don't be too soft.
"You have to charge for this.
"Your time is valuable.
"Your expertise is valuable."
That all is true.
But information, content,
is actually a commodity.
There's an unlimited
amount of free content
on the Internet.
For every business person
that's charging $99 for E-book
or 5,000 a month to be part of a club.
I'm putting out better
fucking information for free.
- Let me explain where you
can take this in your mind.
Put out all the content for free
and the best content
that you possibly can.
Don't put out content
that's tricking people
to sign up for your membership.
- Put out great content
and then realize what
you're actually selling
on the membership side is
actually access not content.
- Okay.
- Right?
- Access to me?
- Correct.
- Okay, yeah.
- So for example, Bec,
you've consumed..
Obviously, if you're on
this call, you know who I am
and you consume my content, right?
- Right.
- But what I'm doing for you right now,
I'm going very detailed
to your actual situation.
I just provided you, potentially,
more value in 49 seconds
than I have in a year
worth of free content
because you got access to me
and I could get context
and I can go deeper.
So, I think the balancing act is,
put out unlimited free content
and fucking save the
world, like I love doing,
but then to make your business,
create a access variable that,
that's what somebody's
really paying for, right?
- Right.
- Because a lot of the
times when people are like,
"Well premium content
is what I'm charging for
"and here's..."
What's really happening there is,
most of the free content
is really just a gateway
and manipulation content to get people
to pay for the actual membership
and that's why it
doesn't feel good to you.
But if you flip it and you say,
"Here's all my best content for free,"
which is then gonna
lead to people trusting
and loving me and if they can afford
and are interested in access,
see how I switched?
- Yes.
And then I have another
challenge that I'm hearing
that's different from other people
that have been on the calls.
There're other people
may be able to relate to.
I'm a mom as well and I
work from home and so,
a lot of people are feeling they have
all this extra time but
now I have my child at home
that I'm helping several
hours a day with homework
and so it's actually
taking away from the time
I would spend on my business.
So I'm having to be very mindful about
everything I'm doing but also,
being in health, I can't not sleep.
I need to walk the walk.
That's the big challenge that's coming up.
- What grade is the...
We're talking about one child or two or?
- Just one and God bless
people who have more than one.
(laughs)
- What grade is he or she in?
- He's in third grade.
- Third?
- Yeah, and it sounds like
it wouldn't be a lot of work
but I'm telling you, it's
like, four hours a day.
(laughs)
- But honestly, two things.
One, I have a very passionate
point of view on this.
A, to me, for example,
if he missed all third grade curriculum
between now and the end of the year
but he spent an hour talking with you,
walking around the block,
I believe, this is one
man's point of view,
I'm not necessarily right,
I believe that's a
greater impact on his life
when he's 27 than getting
his cursive writing
or base multiplication down.
That being said, I don't get
to parent your child, you do.
I would say this,
take it from somebody
who checked the fuck out
by third grade, don't over
worry about this thought
that if you don't crush
these four hours a day,
that your poor son's gonna
be behind in fourth grade.
- Right, right.
Well we have that mindset,
my husband and I, for sure
and we're outdoor people and so, yeah.
- Use that.
Then, let him fucking
have summer vacation now
and fucking abandon it.
(Becky laughs)
I mean this though.
- Yeah.
- I understand and I'm...
Find the right...
Don't overthink the ideology.
Like reverse engineer the
reality of the situation.
Don't let those four hours
create anxiety for you
while you also have to also
create this financial stability
and stay all healthy.
I would wildly argue,
out of your own health
and building financial
stability for your family,
that the curriculum
part of the third grade,
four hours per day is by
far the least important.
Of course, you want
him to learn discipline
but there's a lot...
This is a huge opportunity for you
to do a lot of different things with him,
so, I would think big on this.
- Yeah, so, part of it is
having him do something
while I'm on these very intimate
one on one calls with clients
and I don't want him on the iPad all day
doing something unproductive.
- Why?
I would argue that that
might be productive.
I would argue him exploring the iPad
and navigating a technology
communication infrastructure
is potentially more productive
than him doing fucking,
some sheets that the
teacher made you print out.
I mean that.
I think you've demonized technology.
You're fucking trying
to build an entire life,
a business around using technology.
You and I are talking to each other
right now through technology.
Had there been no Internet...
This fucking Corona happened in '88,
we'd all be fucking not
interacting, really isolated.
We demonize technology when
technology brings happiness.
I would argue, your son would learn more
by exploring that iPad,
whether that's watching
Cartoons on YouTube Kids or not.
I am not convinced that
him following the state-mandated
curriculum of third grade,
(mumbles) every fucking kid
(Becky laughs)
and I like how you're laughing about this.
(mumbles)
I would rather you spend
two of the four hours
really digging through the
Internet to finding some
unique things that he could (mumbles)
Unique apps, unique...
If you spend two hours of the four hours,
right now, today, looking
at all YouTube Kid shows
and all kids apps and
creating your own curriculum,
let him watch Lil Vee and
become a fucking entrepreneur.
Let him watch a compassion show for kids,
let him watch "Old Mr. Rogers"
I would argue, do not demonize
the functionality of an iPad.
Don't put paper on a
pedestal and a laptop not.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- We demonize the mechanism, that's crazy.
My husband would high five you
because he's in the technical
field and he's like,
"This handwriting, he's
never gonna use it."
(laughs)
So, I can relate.
- (mumbles)
and everyone's like, "oh, it's
so nice you wrote a note."
I'm like, "what if the note
said, "You fucking suck.""
Like, that's the message, not
the fucking note, believe me.
Go listen to your husband a little more.
- Thank you.
I have one more thing.
Everyone make a request of you.
I wanna offer you a gift.
- Okay.
- So, somewhere in the future,
if you ever need help with
health in your office,
in your business, that's
something that I do
and I would love to help.
- I love it.
So, send me an email to gary@vaynermedia
and say "It's Becky with
the kid that's on the iPad
"in third grade" and
we'll see what we can do.
I'll get you in touch with Claud.
Thank you.
- Great.
All right, take care.
- Okay, bye, Bec.
Instagram, I'm not
gonna hold this anymore.
There's a link to this
live on my Facebook.
It's in my Instagram URL right now.
What's up Moondog Rex, (mumbles)
- [Dustin] Andrew's on now.
- Andrew.
- [Dustin] Just so you know, it's 9:55.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I know, I gotta go in five minutes.
Everybody, I got to cut today's short.
We'll do two hours
tomorrow again, I think.
Is that right Dustin?
Is that what we (mumbles)
- [Dustin] Yeah.
- Okay, I got to go to a
finance meeting for Vayner.
So, real life, shit, so
let's sneak in real quick.
Andrew, you got a question.
- For sure, my man.
So first of all, thank
you for having me on.
But, basically my question was,
if I wanna make a kind of content,
that I feel might ostracize
me from the people
that are closest to me, how
do I get over that fear?
- I apologize.
I was unfortunately not paying attention.
One more time again?
(Andrew laughs)
- No man, you're good, you're good.
No my question was, if
I am intending to make
a kind of content, right?
Through YouTube, new media.
Instagram, TikTok, all that stuff,
and I feel like there's a possibility that
it could ostracize me from the people
that are closest to me
by the nature of it,
how do I get over that?
What's the move?
- Easy.
By realizing that anybody who be ostracize
or not like you as much about you talking
about something that you're passionate
and interested in talking about
is somebody that is not something
that you need to be valuing.
They need to love you, all of you.
All the true of you.
What, are you gonna live a fake life?
Like, you gonna maintain
friends and family
predicated on things that...
You're literally not gonna
talk about the things
that you wanna talk about in life
because your best friend
or your mom or your uncle
or younger sister or your homies
are gonna think it's weird
or inappropriate or like...
You don't want those friendships anyway.
I mean that.
- True.
- And I promise you, don't
underestimate friends and family.
They tend to step up.
- Okay, understood.
- It's an interesting thought,
right?
- It is.
- I liked the way you reacted
and I've never really
said that before myself.
You know, this "Tea With
GaryVee" thing might be good,
like (mumbles).
We underestimate parents,
friends, and family.
I think they tend to step up more
because 80% of them actually love you
and they wanna (mumbles) your true self.
I think you need to put out the things
you need to put out in the world.
- Cool, okay.
- Is it political, is
it sexual, is it weird?
Is is not even that serious?
- No, basically, well, firstly,
I've never been myself
my whole fucking life.
Like that's just the facts of it because--
- Andrew.
Oh, actually go ahead and finish.
Because?
- No, no.
Because, essentially no one knows
that I swear like a sailor,
no one knows my interests
and shit like that
just because it's like...
I feel like it's probably because...
What's up?
- 'Cause you have to be a good boy.
- Exactly, exactly.
But like, the content that I wanna make
I want it to be as honest as possible
because I wanna document like,
essentially growing up like,
when you're way fucking behind.
Like I'm 23 and I'm in
a spot where it's like,
I have to become like a real person
and I feel like it's something
a lot of people can relate to
and I wanna document that journey,
one, just to have the content of it
for practice, for the future,
and also, in case anyone needs any help,
they can pull from that.
But the biggest thing is, it'll make me,
it'll force me to be accountable
and actually do the shit,
you know what I mean?
So, that's kind of where
this is coming from.
- You're gonna win.
- Cool.
- I love everything I just heard.
(Andrew laughs)
You're not behind, the
fact that you're self aware
that you've never been
yourself is a huge win.
It's the first step.
Most people can't see the first step.
64% of the people in your
life are gonna step up
and love you so much for this,
and the 36% that won't, will
get over it in six months.
(Andrew laughs)
- Fair enough, fair enough.
- All right brother.
- Hey man, I appreciate it and (mumbles)
- I think it's something really good.
Who are you most worried about?
Your mom or?
- My family.
- Of course.
- My mom, yeah.
- Dude, your mom will love you.
Maybe your sailor mouth
(mumbles) for a little bit,
maybe it will embarrass her
at work for a couple of weeks,
maybe it will tear down the ideology
that you're this perfect little Saint
but she's gonna love you cold, bro.
- True facts man.
Thank you.
- Know what I mean?
- Absolutely, I needed that.
- She'll secretly be proud of you.
(Andrew laughs)
- That's the truest shit.
That's exactly it, yeah, yeah.
- Talk to you soon.
- Yeah man, take care.
- All right everybody.
Hope you enjoyed today's
episode of "Tea With GaryVee"
I'm super excited to be doing this show.
(gulps)
I like when the tea gets cold by the end.
That iced tea life is good shit too.
I appreciate all of you,
I'll see you tomorrow 9:00 a.m. eastern.
I hope this brought value.
My team will now be chopping
up a ton of content.
We'll put it throughout the day.
I love you.
Dustin thank you so much.
Let's get quicker on the
ones and twos tomorrow.
- [Dustin] Yes sir.
- And I appreciate all of you.
Have a great, great, great,
great, great, great day.
I promise you, you will
look back at this Pandemic,
as long as you don't lose a loved one,
as a good thing.
It is a reset, it is one
step back, two steps forward.
You will find better jobs, you
will start better businesses,
you'll learn how to save,
you'll learn how to be
grateful for simplicity.
I love you all very much.
I'll see you soon.
(upbeat music)